[Musique]
on va voir maintenant des hommes qui se
sentent attaqués brimés et qui se
réunissent pour se défendre c'est
l'association pour la condition
masculine et nous allons voir un comité
de direction c'est une association
fondée depuis un an et demi c'est un
reportage de sophie richard et anis
dollar rappelle son objet c'est l'étude
en commun par des hommes des femmes des
rapports qui doivent constituer entre
dans la société actuelle et c'est la
défense des droits des hommes et des
enfants face aux conséquences de
l'évolution de la condition féminine
je vais donc demander à jacques massard
de nous dire quelques mots concernant
les enseignements de ce sondage
d'opinion sur la garde des enfants de
parents séparés
qu'est ce qu'on doit penser du résultat
de ce sondage
premièrement ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que nous avons eu vraiment des
réponses massive
le deuxième enseignement je crois que
c'est le l'enseignement capitale c'est
la réponse à la question numéro 2 qui
disait estimez-vous que l'enfant devrait
avoir le droit de choisir le parent avec
lequel il veut vivre et nous obtenons un
oui à 92 5%
vous êtes l'un des fondateurs de ce
mouvement pourquoi ce titre condition
masculine ce titre effectivement on nous
l'a pas mal reprocher on a fini par le
choisir pour bien nous situer et pour
bien marquer que on ne souhaitait pas
traiter uniquement des questions de
divorce et des questions de pair et
l'ours et or le titre exact aurait été
très long ça aurait été par exemple
défense de l'équité entre les hommes et
les femmes ou défense des droits des
enfants et tout de suite on nous aurait
pris pour quelqu'un qui défend les
femmes parce que quand on parle d'équité
entre les hommes et les femmes
légalistes un sésame les femmes c'est ça
on pense simplement on constate qu'il ya
un changement chez les femmes
et on dit que il doit savoir par
conséquent un changement chez les hommes
aussi pour un secrétariat la condition
masculine
non nous nous pensons que les plus
graves problèmes actuellement se pose au
niveau des enfants
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
demandé un secrétariat d'état l'enfant
se retrouvent pensez vous que les armes
de ce mouvement sont des hommes bien
dans leur peau sont des amoureux
non ce serait faux de dire que l'on sont
des hommes qui sont dans ce mouvement
sont des gens bien dans leur peau c'est
pas vrai puisque on vous a dit tout à
l'heure que dans la majorité des cas nos
adhérents étaient des écorchés vifs qui
avait subi et supporter des situations
particulièrement détestable mais vous
savez je vous invite à un supporter de
cars ou ne supporterait pas parce que
vous êtes femme et tes doigts vous
favorise haut niveau notamment des
divorces pour vous dire que vous seriez
pratiquement dans le même situation que
nous sommes et ce que nous tentons de
faire dans le mouvement c'est de faire
que des gens se dépasse à ce niveau là
et c'est pas facile
il semble que dans les problèmes de
famille les hommes
soit inférieure face et c'est une c'est
une constatation quand on regarde un peu
autour de soi vivre les jeunes couples
on constate que c'est l'homme qui
s'efface c'est l'homme qui cède toujours
c'est l'homme qui est dedans on te dire
et c'est la femme qui est arrogante et
pimpante envoie ça autour de nous tous
surtout chez les jeunes
mais est-ce que vous pensez que que
cette évolution du père s'intéressant
ses enfants quelque chose de finalement
notre air essence c'est en raison de
cette évolution de la condition féminine
je veux dire l'acte et l'activité
professionnelle des femmes que le père a
été amenée si vous voulez apprendre sa
place au foyer
lennar de la vérité je crois que c'est
le c'est l'opposé de la féminité et je
pense que comme tous les contraires qui
s'attire la féminité devrait attirer la
virilité et l' inverse également la
virilité
oui c'est de pouvoir d'abord de faire
des enfants
ensuite 2 enfin si la vérité masculine
c'est de pouvoir satisfaire sa femme sur
le plan satisfaction aussi bien
actuellement je lui déconseillerais de
se marier
pourquoi parce que je trouve que les
lois sont mal faites actuellement
concernant le mariage
d'ailleurs je dirais exactement la même
chose à mes gars ont écouté pour mon
fils mes filles
moi je souhaiterais que si elles ont
envie d'avoir une vie professionnelle
elle puisse la voir
mais si elles ont envie d'être mère de
famille elle puisse également l'être et
je souhaite la même chose pour mais pour
mes garçons si ils ont envie d'être des
pères de famille qui puisse l'être dans
la plénitude de d'un père est également
s'ils veulent une profession qui puisse
avoir une prophétie vous étiez
députation nationale est-ce que vous
avez voté pour l'avortement la
contraception
moi je ne me serais pas opposé à
l'avortement mais ce que je reproche à
cette loi c'est que une femme qui le
avorté doit prendre une grande quantité
d'avis un petit peu par tout un tas de
comité de médecins l'assistante sociale
mais pas celui du père ça ça me paraît
quand même choquant pour vous quelle est
la fonction de la femme dans la société
de procréation
[Musique]